Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two, David. Speaking of Joe Rogan,
this is a voicemail that brings up a
really important issue, which we've
not talked about too much. Take a listen.
Speaker 5: Hi, David. I was just watching
one of your clips about Joe Rogan talking about
the monoclonal antibodies. I just wonder why
no one is actually talking about the listed
possible side effects on Regeneron's website.
Yes. Monoclonal antibodies. Everyone's talking
about possible side effects for a vaccine, but
nobody seems to want to talk about the possible
side effects from the monoclonal antibodies.
Maybe you should check that out.
Speaker 1: This is a very important point,
so we've talked before, there's a group that
is either against or skeptical of the vaccines,
partially on the basis that we have this great
treatment monoclonal antibodies that once you
get COVID. So first of all, of course, I prefer
prevention rather than cures. As a general thing,
so we have to even separate the antibody
treatment and vaccines on that basis.
But when you look at the claims made about the
vaccine that these antibody supporters don't
make about the antibody treatment, they say, well,
the vaccine is experimental. The Pfizer vaccine is
fully approved by the FDA, whereas the monoclonal
antibodies are only approved by emergency use
authorization. That's not a good argument. They
say, Well, I don't trust Big Pharma, which is why
I'm against the vaccines. The antibody treatment
is also made by Big Pharma, so that's not a good
argument. They say, well, there's a financial
incentive on the vaccination. Well, it is far
less profitable to do a regimen of three doses
of vaccine than it is to do a regimen of the
monoclonal antibodies. We're talking about
thousands of dollars versus under 100 total
full cost for a full regimen of vaccines. So the
financial argument also doesn't make sense. But
then you get to the side effects and the advocates
of the antibodies instead of the vaccine.
Never talk about the list of possible side
effects, and I'm going to tell you what they are.
This is for the antibody treatment. Fever, chills,
nausea, headache, shortness of breath, low blood
pressure or high blood pressure. Rapid heartbeat
or slow heartbeat. Chest discomfort and pain
weakness confusion. Tired wheezing, lip swelling,
face swelling, throat swelling rashes, including
hives, itching, muscle aches, feeling faint,
dizzy and or sweaty. These reactions may be severe
or life threatening. You may experience new or
worsening symptoms after receiving the treatment,
including fever, breathing difficulty and
some of the other things that I mentioned.
It is unknown if these symptoms are because
of the treatment or because the progression
of COVID could be affected and exacerbated,
exacerbated by the antibody treatment. You also,
because it is an intravenous therapy, you can
have pain, bleeding, skin bruising, soreness,
swelling and even infection where you have that
I've put in. These are not all the possible side
effects of the antibody treatment. Not a lot of
people have been given the antibody treatment,
says Regeneron, compared to hundreds of millions
of people who have been given the vaccine.
It also is disclaimed and stipulated by Regeneron
that the COVID monoclonal antibody treatment
could interfere with your own body's ability
to fight off future COVID infections and
reduce your immune response to vaccination
against coronavirus. That is a mouthful,
and all of these people saying, well, the
vaccine's experimental, so are the antibodies.
But and and no longer is the vaccine experimental,
at least not the Pfizer. And I don't I don't want
those side effects from the vaccine. Look at the
list of possible side effects from the monoclonal
antibody treatment. I'm not against the treatment
when it is the appropriate treatment. It can be
a really great thing. Works better than placebo.
You've got to be sick, though. I would prefer not
to get sick in the first place, but a very good
voicemail and an important topic. And yet another
thing to keep in mind about those advocating
for the monoclonal antibodies instead of the
vaccine when they are two completely different
things, the antibodies are a tool if you get sick.
But we have other tools to try to prevent us from
getting sick in the first place. On the bonus
show today, we will talk about the Glenn Maxwell
guilty verdicts five out of six charges. We will
talk about states hoarding welfare funds even as
the need for aid grows, and we are going to talk
about the imminent increase of the California
minimum wage to $15 per hour. All of those
stories and more on today's bonus show.
Unidentified: Sign up at Join Patricof.